hey everyone it's Justine and today
we're checking out a brand new type of
drone this is the hover air X1 and I'm
so excited to show this to you as you
may know I'm a huge fan of flying drones
but what makes this so much different
there's no controller and this will fly
by itself it'll take off from your palm
it'll fly pre-programmed routes and you
really don't have to do much of anything
at all it does all the work for you a
huge thank you to hover air for
partnering with me on this video I can't
wait to show you more now first things
first we've got to unbox so we have two
colors I've got the white one and the
black one
here oh look at these we have more boxes
to unbox inside of the Box battery
charging Hub and the
battery here it is look how cool it
looks it's so like this is so tiny like
look at this I can actually put this in
my pocket I mean it's smaller than my
phone almost here's the black one
[Music]
they both look so good have a little
carrying case and a cable I like that
they color coordinated the USBC cables
look at this tiny carrying bag it's so
cute what you got in that bag a
drone s we've got our
[Music]
battery so I've been outside testing out
the new hover a X1 here in Hawaii and
this has by far exceeded my expectations
now when I first heard about this I was
like okay cool it's a palm siiz selfly
camera is that actually going to be any
good yes it is and it is so impressive
the coolest thing about it is you don't
have to really think when you're using
it and the biggest learning curve for me
as a drone pilot who's been flying
drones for a really long time is
learning to trust the process normally
I'm the one in control you have to
always be on the sticks ready to control
the Drone there's so many little things
that I love about it I mean look at this
it just folds right out just like that
and within seconds you're ready to get a
really awesome shot I've been at an
event here in Hawaii and I've just been
carrying this around in my yoga pants
pocket and it's honestly smaller than my
phone and it's so easy to use you just
press the button to turn it on and then
it's cool because it will connect to an
app but it does have these buttons that
are right on the top that will allow you
to choose the different types of flight
modes that you want to fly in case you
forget what one of them does it'll tell
you see now
[Music]
follow orbit bird Eye Custom and if you
want to adjust the distance on any of
these you just do a long press in that
specific setting and it'll let you zoom
out 20 ft zoom out 30 ft all of these
settings can also be customized inside
of the app but it's great if you don't
have your phone or you just want to get
a quick shot you can do everything right
here
[Music]
yeah
look at it look how fast it's
going dude you're
[Music]
cool that was awesome
now a lot of drones record audio but the
only thing that you end up hearing from
those devices is the sound of propellers
and the motors with this you can
actually connect it to your phone so
that it'll be able to record the audio
of you talking or whatever it is that's
happening while the Drone is flying
right now I'm actually recording with
the microphone on my phone so you'll be
able to get the sound of me talking one
thing that I'm so impressed with is the
tracking on this I went for a run at the
beach and it was chasing me and it was
so incredible I was running as fast as I
could maybe not that fast but it was
pretty quick time to
land I'm obsessed I love this so
much okay let's
go there she
goes watch that
bump Look at Her
Go
oh gosh it's coming to get me it's
getting
[Music]
me so normally when I think about drones
I think about flying them over Cliffs or
oceans and getting these incredible
aerial views but with this this is
something that I feel is capturing
moments being able to take photos and
videos really quickly of friends and you
don't really have to even think about it
I also love that this will shoot
vertical videos so if you are a vertical
video content creator or you'd like to
share things to stories this is perfect
for that the design of this is really
cool and it's so small and it only
weighs 125 G the enclosed propellers
make it super safe to fly around other
people and when you're ready to start
shooting you just hold it in the palm of
your hand press the button wait 3
seconds and there it goes and when
you're ready to stop recording you just
put your palm out and it'll
automatically land another thing that's
really cool about the X1 is it doesn't
rely on GPS it uses something called Vio
technology this allows it to orient
itself to a surrounding area and it
doesn't have to rely on GPS especially
if GPS signals are weak this way it can
easily transition between locations and
you won't have to worry about losing a
GPS signal I was also pretty impressed
with how stabilized this was in some
windier conditions now obviously you
don't want to be flying this if it's
super windy but there were some times
that I was flying it where there was
some wind and it helds up really well
for this being as small as it is I was
really impressed with the video quality
it does shoot 2.7k at 30 frames a second
and you can shoot 1080 at 60 to get some
slowmo shots I also love inside the app
you can get a preview of what you've
shot so you can quickly download it save
it and share it with friends or on
social media I also like that there's
two versions that you can choose from if
you want the white or the black you have
that option as well the battery just
pops off just like so and the battery
life is actually pretty impressive and I
do like that this comes with two
batteries so if your battery happens to
get low you can pop a new one on and
start recording I had so much fun
testing these out I'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to get more
information or to purchase I so excited
to be adding this to my travel kit and
basically just my everyday bag cuz I
feel like I can put this in my pocket
put it in my purse and at any point I
can just pull this out and get a really
cool shot and with that my friends let's
get a shot to end this
[Music]
video yeah